hey guys pilot season continues that
wisecrack this one is another format
that's going to deal with real world
issues rather than focusing on media and
another reason why we're excited about
this one is this is a continuation of a
collaboration we've had going on for a
while and that is with an artist named
jr. who has been the illustrator for
thug notes since the beginning she did
all the art for this we're super excited
to get it out into the world hope you
guys enjoy it let us know and on with
the show in October of 1992 when the
world wide web was just a few years old
and the idea of streaming terabytes of
pornography was just a far-fetched dream
a presidential candidate had an
interesting idea I will have a unique
mandate that we're going to end the form
the people in detail on the issues
through an electronic townhall so that
they really know what's going on Ross
Perot wasn't talking about the internet
exactly he wanted to use technology to
revolutionize democracy for instance
televised town halls or debates could
allow viewers to chime in with their
phones press one for agree to four
disagree like many others Perot believed
new technology could break down barriers
between decision-makers and the average
citizen now all these fellows $1,000
suits and alligator shoes running up and
down the halls of Congress that make
policy now the lobbyists the PAC guys
the foreign lobbyists what have you
they'll be over there in the Smithsonian
you know
furro wasn't the first to suggest this
kind of electronic democracy and he
won't be the last
for those who lamented the corporate
controlled media or the limited flow of
information in authoritarian regimes the
internet was a godsend one wired article
proudly announce that netizens were
better informed and more civically
engaged than their unconnected peers by
1997 a mere 8.5 percent of the
population was considered connected but
they voted more had greater trust in
democracy and were more likely to know
basic information like who the chief
justice's in other words these connected
citizens were a bastion of light in the
political ecosystem but has this light
dimmed was it ever there at all sure we
can now access unprecedented amounts of
information but as you've probably
guessed something is wrong with the
internet let's fast forward to 2010
young people are doing exactly what
future is predicted connecting on
Twitter and coming out in the streets to
protest oppressive regimes in Egypt
Tunisia and elsewhere the media heralded
the Arab Spring as the first social
media revolution the promise of the
Internet in action before the Internet
political organizing was risky business
stump speeches and flyer distribution
were great ways to end up in jail now in
the age of tweets heard around the world
one can instigate change from the safety
of one's own home until your movement is
too large to quell but despite the
praise the internet earned for his role
in the Arab Spring some have argued that
the uprisings prove that the Internet
can actually stifle politics why because
in Egypt at least the real revolution
didn't start until the internet went
dark on January 28 2011 after several
days of widespread protests Egyptian
President Hosni Mubarek shut down the
country's internet like all of it cell
phones - the anticipation of what had
been billed as the biggest of four days
of rallies but the government completely
shut down the internet in an attempt to
stop people from communicating one paper
argued that the lack of internet in
hence off' i'd revolutionary unrest in
three ways it angered those who were
otherwise unaware or uninterested in the
unrest it forced more face-to-face
communication and it decentralized the
rebellion making it even harder to put
down
similarly the Iranian Revolution of 1978
1979 took place only after a news
blackout which raises another question
what if exposure to information doesn't
necessarily compel us to fix and
justices or clamor for a better world
but just makes us more content with the
status quo the author was inspired by
another paper that looked at East
Germans living under communism who had
access to Western media I understand our
gathering today is being broadcast as
well in the East to those listening in
East Berlin you might think that seeing
a world of freedom would inspire the
East Germans to detest their oppressive
regime and spur them to rebel but it did
exactly the opposite
Eastern Germans with access to Western
TV found their life under communism more
tolerable than their peers without it TV
offered an escape from Food lines and
state propaganda why fight for a better
world when you can just watch one why
jump over a shark on water skis if you
can just watch the Fonz do it and why
participate in politics when you can
just retweet someone else's virtue in
2014 researchers looked at these Save
Darfur cause on Facebook what they found
at this point probably won't surprise
you the vast majority of cosmetic rooted
no one else into the cause and
contributed no money to it suggesting
Facebook conjured and illusion of
activism rather than facilitating the
real thing to be fair there are counter
examples like the ALS ice bucket
challenge which raised unprecedented
amounts of money to fight the disease
but entering a credit card number is a
lot different than being an engaged
citizen where problems are a little more
complicated than dumping money into
research and what about our electronic
town halls for the promise that digital
citizens will be more informed than
generations in 2014 a Pew Research poll
claimed that thanks to the Internet
at least people felt more informed but
what should we make of feeling more
informed well as early as 1996 MIT
researchers prophetically declared that
the internet ran the risk of becoming
what they referred to as a cyber Balkans
like the countries of the Balkan
Peninsula which became increasingly
fragmented and hostile toward one
another the internet would create
insular realities for its users in other
words they identified echo chambers 20
years before everyone freaked out about
them
the point is access to information
doesn't necessarily dispel falsehoods it
can amplify them rather than
discrediting flat-earthers anti-vaxxers
and whatever the hell coupe is the
Internet has helped them thrive and for
the rest of us why challenge your own
perspectives when you can find sources
that think like you do so what gives
as one philosopher notes as we produce
more knowledge what we gained in breadth
we lose in depth everyone has an opinion
but is never committed to act on it why
because of what he considers to be two
of the worst calamities of the modern
era anonymity and the press but this
philosopher wasn't talking about the
internet or even the modern era because
he died in 1855 what Soren Kierkegaard
identified as problems in the 1800's
anonymity public opinion and armchair
intellectualism have been given mega
steroids in the age of the Internet
Kierkegaard argued the press invited us
to become detached spectators divorcing
thought from action ideas were
homogenized as everyone began to read
the same sources now we read the same
and hit like and share if we agree no
independent thought needed but before
getting too cynical should we ask is
this the fault of the Internet itself or
things on it like Facebook or blogan
Paul there are tons of examples some
studied and some not of the bright side
of the Internet times where the Internet
helped organize a community or connect
old friends
let people explore who they really are
but rather than looking at specific
content it's important to understand the
modern Internet as a system with a
supreme mandate to produce knowledge
specifically knowledge about you
tailored for you and often produced by
you the internet isn't about what kind
of knowledge is produced it's concerned
with the ever accelerating exchange of
information in general more photos more
Kickstarter's more video watch time it's
a system that cares about scale not
quality not integrity and despite this
ever-increasing exchange of information
the internet seems to generate isolation
wherever it goes from early internet
studies that show users feel more lonely
and depressed on a micro level to the
balkanization of our political landscape
on a macro level whereas internet
evangelist thought that access to
information would connect people like
never before it's managed to do exactly
the opposite but hey at least there's
this
[Music]
me fall back into speech when I wait
[Music]
reefer
[Music]
all right hope you guys enjoyed that as
much as I did a lot of work went into
this we've been working on it since
about February and we actually cited 36
different sources to make the script
work so you guys can access that
research as well as the research for all
of our videos over at wisecrack plus com
it's our patreon site it's because of
our patrons that were able to do video
experiments like this one most
importantly let us know what you guys
think drop us a comment check out our
other pilots the one on fake news and
the film tourists let us know what you
guys like what you don't like your
feedback will let us know what we should
continue doing so appreciate it guys
leave us a comment peace
[Music]